[Applaudissements]
vous êtes déjà là c'est déjà l'heure de
notre rendez vous excusez nous nous
sommes surpris le temps passe si vite
ici françois pourrait faire un jeu avec
les enfants mais il n'a encore rien
trouvé
alors tu n'as toujours pas l'idée mais
n'ont toujours rien vraiment tenir
aujourd'hui j'ai aucune imagination
oh mais c'est affreux aussi françois en
à plus d'imagination on va s'embêter
tous les jours nous ne t'inquiète pas
casimir ça va passer très vite avec
françois seulement et toi est ce que tu
pourrais pas nous faire une bonne betis
qu'un exemple joue lui imagine potash
corp comme et bêtise je les prépare mes
excuse moi tu as raison moi par contre
tu pourrais être peut-être nous faire
non se dit non - justement mais dense
les prépare très longtemps à l'avancé et
lingerie entre ben tant pis on va être
obligé de dire au revoir à nos amis mais
c'est affreux
je ne vais pas rester tout seul à
m'ennuyer ici mais que gémir je suis
désolé mais vraiment je trouve rien
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde souffrent genre
facteurs home dites moi qu'est ce qui ne
va pas vous en faites une tête françois
n'a plus d'idée on ne peut plus faire de
jeu plus plus de gedo dans l'île aux
enfants aux sociétés possible françois
on n'est pas je me prête un petit peu ma
casquette c'est peut-être le le soleil
qui vous enlève aux idéaux merci-facteur
vous êtes très gentil mais je crois pas
que c'est un rappeur abou assi mort
comme vous voulez tonné françois voilà
une lettre expression
si oui mais seulement il faut bien
signer là l'accusé de réception la voilà
allez merci et nous vous tourmenter pas
allez allez à bientôt s'y tient au fait
tu tombes lit la lettre et à haute voix
il sait que c'est capté quelque chose
d'amusant dont spero ce sont des enfants
qui m'écrivent françois nous avait bien
amusé un jour lorsque tu étais déguisé
en clown
en effet twitter assez amusant pique
nique aux essais mais enfin le plus
drôle c'est quand même moi c'est vrai
kazinian mais tu n'es pas gentil avec
françois parce que son numéro de pique
nique en était très réussie merci je lis
je continue tu nous avais promis de
faire revenir le clown pique nique aux
mais il semble que dû oublier ta
promesse nous ne sommes pas contents du
tout signé sylvie jean pierre et
véronique d'accueil à quelque chose qui
allait remarquer à la fin dit à casimir
qu'il est le plus gentil de tous les
maux forte voix c'est une mémoire
préféré rien sylvie jean pierre et
nathalie si un jour vous venez dans
l'île aux enfants
je vous invite à manger un énorme
gloubiboulga tu sais casimir de la
banane écrasée avec de la saucisse de
toulouse
voilà de quoi la relever tout envie de
venir vous voir
oui ta lettre c'est une idée formidable
fait revenir le clown pique nique au oui
oui la dernière fois à la fin de ton
numéro tu te démaquiller devant tout le
monde
cette fois pour changer tu devrais te
maquiller c'est la déroute de maquillage
dans mon kiosque qui va le chercher
oui moi je prends ma chaise et casimir
tu vas chercher les enfants très bien
géré la hongrie m'aider et me dit
apporter ma chaise en miroir
voilà ici
merci casimir je suis à côté le crâne
boutiques et lully parfait allez voir
c'est intéressant et vous chez vous
regardez bien faire un maquillage de
clown c'est pas si facile que ça et oui
tout le monde ne peut pas avoir une tete
drôle naturellement c'est que les clowns
passent des années avant de trouver le
visage qu'ils garderont toute leur vie
oui je commence à faire l'entourage
n'est pas mon maquillage et des yeux car
et je dessine légèrement d'abord je vais
changer l'emplacement des sourcils et m
dos coupe les hommes je dessine très
légèrement d'abord ici je suis content
de mon travail je remplirai et si jamais
je me sentis de tromper je passais donc
j'étais légèrement rives voilà l'autre
côté se précise
vous savez un maquillage de clown
normalement ça se fait tout seul dans sa
loge et personnes assistent un petit peu
aride secrets et les artistes dans leur
loge
c'est un petit peu comme chez eux
françois termine le tracé au crayon il
va commencer à poser les couleurs
notamment le blanc qui est très
important le blond de clown il étonné
letchimy des sources ici je vais face et
les 1000 jeux remplir tout le carré de
l'oeil de blanc dans un maquillage de
clown un jeu beaucoup sur les contrastes
de couleurs là et le sorcier et étape
teddy soret ça changera complètement
l'expression brill sont aussi placées là
ça change complètement à l'autre
maintenant je vais remplir complètement
tablant le car est là il fallait pas
rater des tracasseries
on passe en même temps là et parce que
ça fait marrer et c'est très très
méticuleux très précis chez vous les
enfants qui regardent et si ça vous
donne envie de faire un maquillage de
clown demandez votre maman vous prêter
ses maquillages à la et ses débuts mais
déjà on commence à savoir une petite et
teddy bear way i 6 avec application je
vais te dirai tout le visage de clown
je sais pas j'ai besoin vous croyez moi
vous connaissez les noms des dans un
couple de clunia le clown blanc
quelquun sérieux qui ne fait pas de
bêtise et rien n'existe vous avez déjà
qu au cirque alors comment ça se passe
moi j'ai jamais plus de cirque
justement ce que je trouve ses deux
difficiles dans le cirque c'est le nom
des différentes sortes d'acrobates ville
à paris où les connaissances qu'ils
aimeraient savoir apparaître temps
regardez ce que vous montrez à savoir
comment s'appelle ce qui marche comme ça
sur un fil
moore spécialiste avait
les funambules c'est ça oui oui et ce
qu'ils y envoient les choses en l'air
comme sa longueur oui très bien et je
laisse outil qui jongle avec les pieds
sanon message c'est un nombre très
compliqué tu sais quoi je voulais jouer
les antipodistes les antipodistes ah oui
on allait voir mais françois de son
maquillage alors 17 ans font donc le
pique nique auriez dit 500 termine le
blanc là on joue sur les contrastes des
couleurs et le noir et blanc de rouge de
marrant ça avant là c'est pas encore
terminée tiens la bouche encore elle
modifie complètement l'expression la
boue quelle couleur la bouche et non la
ligne rouge évidemment très important la
bouche c'est ce qui donne expression vue
c'est ce qui donne l'illusion que le
clown riz en permanence avec loulou qui
sont tristes parfois exactement quelle
est en droit d'être au risque a bien sûr
une habitude de dire que déjà les comics
et des clones qui font rire les foules
sans l'avis des gens très triste
c'est pas forcément vrai quasiment tous
les immigrés tu n'es pas triste on avait
un casier meyrin voilà je suis un grand
nostalgique
[Rires]
voilà des petits triangles soleil et
lune est alors attends attends casimir
donné c'est une des dernières opérations
voilà le nevada un grand coup lui
regarde ôter leur plaisir
on a le nez elle étrille l'élastique
ça tient avec un élastique ça se voit
mais ce n'est pas grave c'est une
convention on admettrait bien de devoir
l'élastique
mais au passage oui je te calmes 6 vous
un petit peu oui mais même si on le voit
simplement est maintenant bien mes
cheveux derrière la perruque principe
est finie
quand je dis la perruque seca stockera
les travail études en fait perruque
il ya des cheveux que sur le côté je
rentre bien les cheveux ainsi que les
enfants est ce que vous connaissez la
candidate sous laquelle s'abritent les
spectateurs et un chapiteau très bien et
bien voilà je crois que maintenant il ne
me manque plus que le costume pour être
le clown pique nique aux je le trouve
très réussi aussi je lise il va casimir
casse-cou ça y aura excusez moi monsieur
le
le clown pique niquons je croyais que
c'était mon ami françois mais enfin
casimir du tu ne reconnais pas
si si je vous rends connais très bien
vous êtes le clown pique nique aux les
amis de mon ami françois dit monsieur
pique nique aux ruines entre nous vous
feriez bien de dire à votre ami françois
de se maquiller un peu en clown
il aurait l'air moins sinistre
je suis
[Musique]